turkey the wall hit wonder and
absolutely amazing birth stuff onion
orange garlic thyme and bay leaf season
trouble butter this little beauty helps
to take the turkey to a different
division these cost fifty quid for that
size yes it's expensive but boys are
worth
don't chop the truffle too small because
we want to taste and identify the
truffle parsley tarragon salt touch of
pepper tablespoon of olive oil and that
stops the butter from burning
so you plug them back and sit
saturate skin from meat
hiding back in like butter
mess up
salt pepper olive oil roast citrus
breadcrumbs pancetta
onion
time good old chefs trick and pulldown
and just peel off his lovely flowers
high notes
but ER
bread
orange
lemon
and they start browning sprinkle the
orange and lemon breadcrumbs
lemon juice
now yeah usually rs10 for keeps nice and
warm when it cooled down slowly so the
breasts become really nice and moist
calm what you can cement of course is
that amazing truffle absolutely
beautiful
turkey with truffle butter and citrus
breadcrumbs done the most important
Baffert everyone until do not slice it
thin me okay turn it round the slice it
about an inch thick
those gooseberries are just nice and
soft and plump gimme gimme gimme
DUP with gooseberry sauce done